with foreign fires forest fires covering
an area about the size of the state of
rhode island
other western states including oregon
montana and colorado were ablaze with
unprecedented damaging
wildfires at the same time other parts
of our country were being battered by
violent extreme weather the people of
iowa experienced one of the most
costly thunderstorms in history
hurricane force winds caused
seven and a half billion dollars in
economic damage in flattened i'm told
over half of that state's corn and
soybean crops in one day
coastal towns in southern states like
florida like louisiana like south
carolina were battered
by hurricane after hurricane after
hurricane
in the summer of 2020 last summer
we saw the most hurricanes of the
atlantic ocean
in recorded history
despite all of this the trump
administration took a step to
undo one of the key tools available to
us
to combat methane emissions that
contribute greatly
to climate change the methane
reset resistant rule was a stark
departure from the widely accepted
science-based and common sense view that
we should protect people
and our planet from the dangers of
methane
in promulgating the methane rescission
rule the trump administration
ignored the global scientific community
including epa's own agency scientists
who warned that the extreme weather
events in 2020 were just the tip
of the iceberg of consequences we can
expect
if we don't keep global warming below an
increase of one and a half degrees
celsius
between now and 20 40.
the bottom line is that the trump
methane rescission rule
would allow more methane pollution
increase public health dangers and bring
us ever closer to the brink of
irreversible climate catastrophe
it is a trump epa action that my
colleagues and i reject today
through the resolution before us
the methane rescission rule stated
methane couldn't be
regulated under the clean air act
we reject that the methane rescission
rule stated
epa couldn't regulate the entire oil and
gas sector from wellhead to
storage we reject that
the methane rescission rule stated
greenhouse gases
couldn't be regulated we reject
that the methane
rescission rule also reversed epa's
long-standing position
on what is required to regulate a
pollutant
making it harder for epa to implement
clean air and climate protections
we reject that as well
with approval of this resolution though
epa can
and should still move forward to
strengthen methane standards for the oil
and gas
sector in the future this effort is also
very timely
coming on the heels of president biden's
climate commitment
for our nation to reduce emissions by 50
from 2005 levels
by the end of this decade by 2030.
passing this resolution will be good for
our health
passing this resolution will be good for
our planet and passing this resolution
will be good
for america's economy that's why so many
states so many environmental groups and
even a number
of significant oil and gas companies
support this
resolution joining over 60 environmental
groups as well as 20 states attorney
general
seven major oil and gas companies
support today's resolution to
reinstate requirements to control
methane emissions
from the environment environmental
defense fund to shell
from the league of conservation voters
to bp
from the natural resources defense
council to ecuador
there is a broad consensus among the
stakeholders with different interests
different interests that congress should
reject
and nullify the methane rescission
rule so why do a number of oil and gas
companies want congress to
reject the trump rule restore existing
regulations
and pursue further regulations they know
the best way to boost growth in their
sector
and across the economy is to keep
methane and other
climate pollution in check with
unchecked
methane releases in its operations
natural gas production
and use become part of the climate
problem
not a part of the solution as we
endeavor to drive toward
lower carbon fuels
companies know where the global market
is heading
they know regulations will support
innovation and technology
deployment in their industry bringing
down emission
reduction costs for everyone
i sometimes like to quote albert
einstein
who said among other things this he said
in adversity
lies opportunity think about that in
adversity
lies opportunity we can see that in the
issue of methane pollution
and climate change it presents plenty of
challenges yes that's true
but it also presents a remarkable
opportunity
it's an opportunity for us to protect
our planet
improve the air that we breathe and
strengthen
our economy at the same time the product
that the oil and gas industry is
capturing
can be sold to fuel more homes and
businesses
across the country i want to say that
again too
at the same time the product that the
oil and gas industry is capturing
can be sold to fuel more homes and
businesses
across the country that's why today i
will
gladly vote for this decision for this
resolution rather
which reaffirmed that the clean air act
requires epa
to take action to protect americans from
dangerous pollution
like methane in passing this resolution
today
congress is rejecting the trump rule
baseless
interpretation of the clean air act
and in its place reinstating common
sense
methane public health and climate
protections across the entire oil
and gas sector we're also clearing the
path for additional protections from
methane
and other hazardous climate pollutants
as a senate we're making our intent
clearer
the clean air act gives epa the
authority
and the mandate to establish methane
emission standards even stronger the
ones and we
reinstate with this resolution this
includes all facets of the oil and gas
industry now
and moving forward from product
production
to processing and from transmission to
storage
we're saying to epa loud and clear
it is your mission to protect the
environment
to protect human health and public
welfare
from the dangers of climate pollutants
like methane and there is a lot of work
still to do
before that mission can be achieved
it's time that we get to that work we
don't have a lot of time
to waste and mr uh mr president
i have a couple of unanimous consent
requests i'd like to offer
oneness has placed supportive materials
into the record
and i ask unanimous consent mr president
to enter into the record
several materials in support of senate
joint resolution
14 that's before us today first the body
administration statement of
administration policy
supporting passage of the uh resolution
second two letters of support for
passing this joint resolution one from
the 57 leading environmental and
advocacy groups and another
the shell oil company these ladders
demonstrate the breadth of support for
regulating
this harmful pollution pollutant and
rejecting
the methane precision rule and i ask
unanimous consent
be inserted into the record as
appropriate
without objection that mr president
i got to yield the floor but before i do
i want to salute you
for your role in an earlier day in an
earlier uh an earlier place
your state of colorado for helping to
get this started
or in your debt good work god bless and
with that i yield the floor
the senator from iowa madam president
it's been nearly 100 days
since president biden delivered his
inaugural
inaugural address promising our nation
unity not division
he called on all of us to
listen to one another noting that unity
requires more than words
i was there and i was
listening i was hopeful that he
actually meant what he said
but that very same day
as soon as he reached the other end of
pennsylvania avenue
president biden seemed to forget his own
words
as he began signing a record number
of executive orders with the stroke of a
pen he unilaterally
created a new migrant crisis
by reversing the previous
administration's
successful policies and ceasing
construction of the wall
he also killed thousands of jobs for
american workers
by canceling the excel
pipeline and that was just his
first day on the job
since then the president and his
democratic allies in congress
have used a partisan process to
fast-track trillions of dollars of new
spending for their pricey pet projects
despite the president's call for us
to listen to one another the democrats
are planning to once again
fast track another 2.2 trillion
dollar package being sold as an
infrastructure bill even though it
spends
less on roads and bridges
than it does on parts of the socialist
green new deal and other progressive
priorities and then right after that
they want to ram through another
one trillion dollars
for so-called human infrastructure
the democrats are threatening to end the
right of senators
to debate by abolishing the filibuster
so they can shove through their extreme
agenda
this would fundamentally change the
senate
which has long been known as the world's
not just americas
but the world's greatest
deliberative body in which
every state has equal representation
and every senator is given a
voice in our national conversations
it's an interesting twist for the party
that just
a year ago proudly resisted
nearly every effort put forth to address
the problems
facing our nation
for purely partisan political reasons
democrats even filibustered
yes they filibustered the justice
act that would have provided police
reform
following the deaths of george floyd
and others this week the nation will
have the
opportunity to hear from the author of
that bill
my dear friend senator tim scott of
south carolina
who is delivering the republican
response to the president's address
this evening no one better
represents the type of positive
leadership we need to unify our nation
than tim
he truly is the perfect voice
for the american dream growing up in a
poor
single-parent household tim's mother
worked hard
to make ends meet despite some early
challenges and setbacks
tim successfully started his own
business
and was chosen time and again
to serve in public office
as a senator tim is focused on creating
opportunities
for others by tapping into the potential
of individuals and communities
tim listens and he works hard to bring
people
together and folks
that is what president biden promised
to do but he's not living up to that
promise
frankly the president only seems to be
listening to the far left progressives
within the democratic party
who live on their own liberal
fantasy island
he and his liberal allies on the left
are pushing
tax hikes on working
americans while giving tax breaks
to wealthy coastal elites they are
bringing back corrupt
and costly earmarks democrats want to
defund our police
and abolish ice
they want to remake nearly every aspect
of our economy
with a radical green new deal
the democrats are plotting to pack the
supreme court
with ultra liberal justices and destroy
that institution and to pad their
numbers in congress
democrats are attempting to make
washington d.c
a state does that sound like the unity
and bipartisanship we were promised
on day one it sure doesn't folks
if president biden actually listened to
the voices of americans
who live outside of the dc swamp
he wouldn't be hearing a demand for
any of those radical proposals
the senate is split 50
50 while democrats hold a razor slim
majority in the house of representatives
and according to a recent gallup poll an
overwhelming two-thirds
of americans say they are dissatisfied
with the way things are going in the
united states
based upon those responses it sounds
like the democrats radical
agenda is dividing
not unifying
our country iowans want democrats and
republicans to set aside partisan
differences and work together on our
national
interests they want students to be able
to
safely return to their classroom
and for folks to go back to
work iowans want us to fix
our roads and bridges and expand
broadband
to rural areas they worry about the
growing
global influence of communist china
and the humanitarian and national
security crisis
on our southern border they want us to
protect the american dream
for future generations
folks we can do this
president biden if you are listening
please
hear me out giving in to the deafening
demands of the loudest
on the left and attempting to silence
half of the country will not
solve our problems it will only divide
us more to succeed
we need to consider the voices of all
americans and speak
to what unites us so we can
overcome our challenges
and we can overcome these
challenges together madam president
i yield the floor
madam president the senator from wyoming
first madam president i'd like to
associate myself with the remarks of the
senator from iowa who
did a magnificent job of pointing out
what we are facing as a nation
and i admire her fortitude and her hard
work and her dedication
as the vice chairman of the republican
conference madam chairman 99 days
of madam president 99 days ago joe biden
took office
took the oath of office we were there
he gave an inaugural address he said
quote with unity we can do great things
he said unity is the path forward well
that was the last example of unity and
bipartisanship that we've seen
from president biden he has lost all
credibility when it comes to
bipartisanship
or unity in just 99 days president biden
has already shown himself to be one of
the most
radical presidents in american history
when i'm in wyoming as i am every
weekend and have been over easter as
well traveling the state talking to
people
they ask about two specific issues one
is energy
and the second is the southern border
on these two specific issues madam
president
president biden has already done
tremendous damage
damage to our country damage to our
people damage to our economy
right after his inaugural address about
unity
president biden drove to the white house
sat there went in
and threw the unity speech out the
window and he drew a big target on the
back of american energy and he pulled
the trigger
he shut down the keystone xl pipeline he
ended new fossil fuel projects on
federal lands
and he cut off traditional energy loans
to developing nations that need
our help and look to us for help
well these steps aren't going to reduce
carbon emissions
but they will most certainly reduce jobs
and wages from american energy workers
also on his first day president biden
flipped on the big green light switch
on our southern border he sent out the
word laid out the welcome mat
and people from around the world came
illegally to the united states
he stopped construction on the border
wall and he ended a policy that was
successful the policy was that known as
the remain in mexico policy
now the result wasn't just one crisis it
was two it was a humanitarian crisis
and it was also a national security
crisis
it's a national security crisis because
two-thirds of the border patrol agents
and i went to the border
and went with a number of republican
senators and went on a midnight
patrol with our border agents
and they told us that two-thirds of the
border patrol agents are unable to do
their jobs and keep us safe
unable to be there to enforce the law
and they said that so far people have
come into the country
illegally from 56 different nations
the whole world knows the border is open
our friends know it our enemies
know it and this will make us less safe
as a nation
there's also a humanitarian crisis at
the border caused by president biden
just a month ago a nine-year-old from
mexico died
trying to cross the rio grande river
it's heartbreaking
that's what happens though
this is what happens when more and more
people try to come illegally
to cross our border children who cross
the border
unaccompanied are sent to a facility
that is prepared and appropriate for
about 250 children
the day we were there there were seven
thousand crammed in like sardines
that is joe biden's plan for immigration
ten percent of these children are
testing positive for coronavirus
and we saw the testing process
and we know that every child there was
exposed to coronavirus based on the high
percentage of those who were testing
positive
now as these young people are released
those that have tested negative but have
been just been
exposed in the days before they're being
sent
all across america
they're spreading the virus and unknown
variants of the virus to this country
joe biden is the super spreader of
coronavirus today
democrats think this is just fine vice
president the united states is going to
be up here tonight on capitol hill she
says we're making
good progress nancy pelosi says we're on
a good path on the border
homeland security secretary mayorka says
the border is secure
and closed even though he has also said
this is the worst case
in 20 years for young people and we are
on a path
for up to 2 million illegal immigrants
coming across the border
this year white house refuses to use the
word crisis
in fact when the president and president
and his press secretary have
accidentally called it a crisis and they
both have done that
the white house issued a correction they
said no no not a crisis
only a challenge madam president who do
they think they're
fooling two million illegal immigrants
this year
it's not a challenge it's a crisis it is
chaos at the border it is catastrophic
99 days ago none of this was happening
for 99 days republicans in the united
states senate have repeatedly
looked for common ground with president
biden and the democrats
we've stood for american energy we
worked to secure the border
yet for 99 days those efforts have been
blocked by president biden
and a democrat majority which is hardly
a big majority when it's 50 50
which we would think would be a mandate
to move to the middle
president biden still has a thousand
days or so left in his term
tonight's speech might sound a lot like
his inaugural address with lots of
promises
the american people know talk is cheap
it's time for president biden to start
to practice
what he is preaching thank you madam
president i yield the floor
and president senator from ohio
thank you madam president i'd like to
start by thanking my colleague from
wyoming and
my colleague from iowa for their
comments about where we are as a country
100 days into the biden administration
it's been discouraging that we haven't
seen more bipartisan work
and with regard to the border having
been down there
a couple weeks ago particularly
discouraging that we can't
come up with a bipartisan solution that
deals with the obvious crisis on the
border of course it's a crisis everybody
knows that
including the biden administration the
question is what are we going to do
about it
and some of us have laid out some
proposals that we think would be very
sensible
it could be done on a bipartisan basis
and yet uh
we are not getting the kind of
cooperation from the white house or the
other side of the aisle frankly with
regard to dealing with a clear crisis
in my time here in congress i've tried
to work to bring republicans and
democrats together on issues
i think that's the best thing for our
country i think you get actually better
legislation if you have input from both
sides
and i think you also have more
sustainable legislation if you
don't work in a bipartisan way what
happens when there's a 50 50 senate as
there is now
and where the vice president can supply
the thai vote and if you do things
on the basis of reconciliation or
getting rid of the filibuster which is
what the
uh democratic majority apparently would
like to do
you end up lurching back and forth don't
you so you pass democrat legislation and
then when republicans take over
republican legislation
we should be focusing on american
legislation
in my office we've had some success with
this bipartisan approach
68 of my bills were signed into law by
president obama
82 of my bills were signed into law by
president trump
on important issues like the addiction
crisis job creation natural resource
protection
so it can be done and president biden
knows that he served here in the senate
in fact he
took pride in coming together with
republicans and democrats
to actually have agreements on some of
these tough issues
and although i didn't vote for him
because i thought that president trump
had better policy ideas
coming into this new administration i
was hopeful that president biden would
govern
as he had campaigned he promised to
remember in his campaign to reach out to
republicans and democrats alike
he talked about the need for unity in
fact he gave that same speech
in the primary and in the general
election which i thought took some
courage frankly
to do so in the primary because most of
his opponents did not take that position
and yet now having gotten elected he
seems to have forgotten
the pledges that he made i listened to
his inaugural address intently as i hope
a lot of americans did and certainly my
colleagues did and
he talked again about reaching out going
back to the days when we could work
together and he focused on unity
i was very hopeful with the tone he said
that day and i said so at the time
and yet that rhetoric has not been
matched by
action it hasn't been maxed by action
when it comes to key policy initiatives
they've already put forward including
the latest covet 19 spending bill that
passed in march
remember despite a 50-50 senate and very
tight majority in the house
representatives
there was no outreach to republicans on
the copen 19 legislation
not a single republican was consulted
before unveiling the plan and
once it was out there democrats chose
to work only among themselves and do it
under what's called reconciliation where
they don't need a single
republican vote this despite some of us
having an alternative which we actually
presented to the white house
the next day we were told thank you but
we're going to take the reconciliation
approach
and we don't need any republican input
that's too bad because the covet 19
issue obviously is one where there has
been
not just bipartisanship but
nonpartisanship five times
last year we passed major coveted 19
legislative initiatives with huge
majorities
in one case the biggest bill that cares
package passed with a 97 to nothing vote
here so this is one we had always
been able to work together unfortunately
the byte administration chose the
partisan path
right now the biden administration is
repeating this same mistake as far as i
can tell
because they've introduced their 2.3
trillion dollar infrastructure package
without consulting again any republicans
and we now hear that white house and
some democratic leaders may want to
pass this latest partisan proposal by
reconciliation as well
i hope that's not true because again
this is an area infrastructure where we
have been able to
work together on a partisan on a
bipartisan basis and get things done
in fact typically that's how it happens
with infrastructure last
congress we passed a bill out of the
committee on highways and bridges
with a unanimous vote not just a
majority vote a unanimous vote by
republicans and democrats
but the proposal they've put forward
first is not really about infrastructure
because it dramatically expands the
definition of infrastructure
so that it is it is not at all what
traditionally you would think or i would
think of as
the kind of hard assets roads bridges
ports airports
transit even broadband even the most
generous description
of infrastructure applied to this bill
means that less than 20 percent of it
20 of 2.3 trillion dollars is about
infrastructure
it's about other things and we can have
a debate on those other things
whether it's nursing home subsidies or
whether it's
subsidies to electric car companies or
whether it's child care those are always
we can discuss that they're not
obviously infrastructure issues
by proposing to pay for this huge plan
with taxes on american workers makes it
even worse
so the 2.3 trillion dollar plan is not
mostly infrastructure 80
is not but then the taxes that would
apply to america and to american workers
would be devastating making this
non-competitive in the global economy
again after finally
we were getting our act together and in
2018 and 2019 we saw a big increase in
our economy
large increases in terms of employment
but also wages were going up the lowest
poverty rate in the history of our
country
going back to the 1950s partly because
we were putting in place policies that
made sense in terms of tax reform
to create more incentives to invest and
bring jobs here to this country
that would all be changed under these
tax increases that are being proposed to
pay for
this big new biden infrastructure
package
making us less competitive global
markets and putting american workers
their disadvantage again is not the
right way to go
the american people don't want that
american people think we should be doing
all we can to get businesses back on
their feet right now so people can get
employment and so we can ensure that the
economy continues to improve as we come
out of the coronavirus pandemic
infrastructure again has always been so
bipartisan
why would in this case we want to take
it down the partisan road
past presidents by the way have shown
that they can get big things done
early in their administration so during
this first hundred days there was an
opportunity
to reach out i hope in the second
hundred days that will be different
let me give you a couple of examples
when president bill clinton got elected
he works with republicans and democrats
to pass what was called the north
american free trade agreement
he got a lot of support from the
republican side of the aisle in fact
even more than he got from the
democratic side of the island he pushed
that through
ronald reagan's economic reforms of 1981
passed the senate with an overwhelming
margin of 89 to 11.
last night c-span allowed us to look
back in history at
some of the speeches presidents gave
after they were in their
first hundred days and one was ronald
reagan's speech to the joint session
that i saw last night
it was amazing republicans and democrats
alike were standing because president
reagan said
i want to work with all of you and he
showed he would work with all of them
by passing those economic reforms in
1981.
we should all want the biden
administration to succeed in putting in
place bipartisan policies that help our
constituents
and help our country but that can only
happen if they agree to reverse course
and engage
with republicans in a genuine way that's
clearly what the american people want in
a recent poll
the washington post and abc poll 60
percent of respondents including
two-thirds of independents
said they wanted the buy demonstration
to work with republicans to make his
proposals bipartisan
twice the number that wanted him to
pursue the partisan path chosen so far
i'd suggest to my constituents in ohio
and all americans will be listening
tonight
don't just listen to the rhetoric look
at the actions
because the rhetoric thus far has not
been matched by actions
we were promised by partisanship as a
path toward unity
for the sake of our country it's time to
keep that promise
yield back
madam president senator from north
dakota thank you madam
president i rise today to talk about how
congress can
work together in a bipartisan way to
pass infrastructure legislation
following my
colleagues from ohio from wyoming from
iowa
colleague from north carolina is here as
well there's a real
desire to come up with an
infrastructure package but we want it to
be bipartisan
republicans and democrats agree that
investing in our national infrastructure
is necessary to increase economic growth
ensure global competitiveness
of american businesses and create new
high-paying jobs
in fact just last congress the senate
environment and public works committee
unanimously approved a five-year surface
transportation reauthorization bill
which included about 300 billion for
roads
bridges and that actually uh represents
a 27 percent increase over
the fast act and we really feel that
that
bill with its bipartisan support creates
a
starting point starting point on a
bipartisan
basis for the negotiations that we
should have
in developing the infrastructure package
tonight we expect the president will
outline his american jobs plan
but unfortunately it's not focused on
infrastructure
it's a massive 2.25 trillion tax and
spend bill
that dedicates less than one-third about
600
just over 600 billion toward actual
traditional
infrastructure the administration's plan
would increase the corporate tax
from 21 to 28
resulting in reduced wages increased
costs for consumers
and a reduction in economic growth
the biden plan would revert the u.s tax
system to a worldwide tax system
increasing taxes on u.s multinational
corporations reducing the
competitiveness of american businesses
and driving u.s jobs and profits to
other countries
the 2017 tax bill brought the us
into a territorial tax system for the
taxation of multinational
companies it's worked
from 1985 to 2017
85 u.s based multinational corporations
took advantage of
corporate inversions resulting in a 9.5
billion dollar tax revenue loss to the
us government
since 2000 since the 2017
jobs and tax cut act there have been no
corporate inversions
the biden plan would abandon this
successful approach
further the administration has proposed
a 35 billion dollar tax increase on u.s
energy producers endangering u.s energy
independence
costing u.s jobs and empowering foreign
energy
and excuse me empowering foreign
energy production a recent study from
the national association of
manufacturers shows that nearly 1
million jobs
would be lost in the first two years
alone if this tax
increase goes through tonight we
expect to hear from president biden on
additional proposals to increase taxes
on american workers
as well as increase our debt and deficit
for instance
we've seen reports today that the
president is going to seek
to repeal stepped-up basis
now while the administration indicates
there may be some exceptions
repealing stepped-up basis would place a
significant
and complex tax burden on small
businesses
and particularly family farms ranches
not only in my state of north dakota but
across the country
right now the average age of our farmers
in america is about 60 years old
and we need to get the next generation
into farming
but they can't do it if they have to
sell the farm
to pay the tax a repeal
of stepped-up basis would increase the
cost of capital discourage investment
reduce the wages of workers and stun
economic growth in both the immediate
and long term
a recent analysis from ernst and young
shows that eliminating stepped-up basis
will result in the loss of 80
000 jobs a year for the next 10 years
and a loss of nearly 10
billion dollars in gdp growth per year
while we continue to emerge from the
kova 19 pandemic we should not be
constraining economic growth by
increasing taxes
and regulation instead we should be we
should maintain the pro-growth
low tax regime put in place in 2017 by
the tax cut
and jobs act and make targeted
investments in traditional
infrastructure while reducing regulatory
barriers to provide long-term certainty
to americans last week i met with
president biden at the white house
to share this very message that
republicans stand ready to work with the
administration
and our democrat colleagues on the
infrastructure package
in a bipartisan and targeted manner
focusing on updating our roads
bridges railways airports broadband and
other traditional
infrastructure we also support investing
in energy infrastructure
including enhancing the 45q tax credit
to accelerate the deployment of carbon
capture and sequestration
technology as well as pipelines to
provide the safe and efficient
transportation
of our natural resources we should be
working together for the american people
to enact policies that will improve
our national infrastructure to this end
i want to highlight a number of
bipartisan proposals that i've been
working on with my colleagues
across the aisle i've introduced
bipartisan legislation with senator
smith
senator capital senator whitehouse and
others to enhance
the 45q tax credit for carbon capture
and sequestration
also senator smith and i have
legislation that would empower
rural electric and telecom cooperatives
to refinance
existing debt reinvest in improved
energy efficiency and expand broadband
delivery
to more of their rural customers
likewise the senate finance committee
likewise
senate finance committee chairman wyden
and i have introduced a bill that would
encourage
private investment in infrastructure by
expanding private activity bonds
and creating a new infrastructure tax
credit
additionally i've introduced legislation
with senator bennett
that ensures that our farmers ranchers
and producers have the regulatory
flexibility needed to safely and
efficiently move their products
livestock in particular to market while
ensuring the safety of all road users
we don't need to burden hard-working
americans with increased taxes in order
to pay for this
there are a number of potential options
to provide the necessary
revenue for a targeted infrastructure
package
for example we can make modest changes
to our user fee based highway trust fund
system
ensuring that electric vehicles pay into
the fund
we can repurpose unused federal spending
including
using funds from the recent american
rescue plan
act we could also use revenue generated
from energy production
on federal lands and these are just a
few
of the ideas we put forward last week
ranking member capital of the
environment and public works committee
along with ranking members of banking
commerce energy and finance committees
on the framework of almost 600
billion infrastructure package which
focuses
investment in traditional infrastructure
we should use this framework and begin
working through regular order
in a committee driven process to produce
a bipartisan
targeted infrastructure bill that does
not increase taxes
on american workers
way we truly upgrade our infrastructure
create jobs
and keep our economy growing
madam president that's the right
approach and we need to work in a
bipartisan manner
to get it done and with that i yield the
floor
madam president yes senator from north
carolina
thank you madam president i want to
thank my colleague from north dakota and
ohio
and wyoming and iowa have spoken before
me and my colleague from kansas after me
i think senator portman ended his
statement by saying
we've heard the rhetoric but we haven't
seen the actions
well north carolina our state motto in
latin
is ese quamba dairy it means
to be rather than to see
and i think our state model does a good
job of summarizing the first hundred
days of the biden administration
as a presidential candidate joe biden
made it seem
he would govern as a moderate pragmatic
deal maker
and he set the bar high in his inaugural
address he said
my whole soul is in this bringing
america together
uniting our people and uniting our
nation
i ask every american to join me in this
cause
i was actually inspired by that
statement and i'm one of the
one of the americans who was willing to
work for him on that cause in fact i was
one of
10 republicans that had the first
official meeting with the president to
see if we could come to common ground
on the covid relief package after having
successfully
passed five of our bipartisan coveted
relief packages
last congress unfortunately
the president's actions have not
corresponded with his promises
to date instead of leading on his
instincts to bring america together
president biden has followed his
advisor's recommendations to go it alone
he's pushed a highly partisan
ideologically driven agenda
and you don't need to take my word for
it
new york representative okaza court
ocasio-cortez recently declared that
president biden has
exceeded the expectations of
progressives
indeed there's been a lot in biden's
agenda for the left to like
it's an agenda designed to pass with no
need for moderation
and not a single republican vote no
consensus
whatsoever proposing tax hikes
on american families and businesses at a
time that they're trying to rebound from
the pandemic
ladies and gentlemen we are in the
middle of a national an emergency
we are in the middle of a pandemic we
have spent and
appropriated billions of dollars to
health care to businesses to recover
and now long before
the pandemic's been declared or the
emergency national emergency has been
declared
done we're talking about taking those
same dollars away
offering mixed messaging and failed
policies that have caused a humanitarian
and security crisis at the southern
border
is another issue when i went down to the
border about a month ago
the press secretary said it's not a
crisis it's a situation
now a month later the press secretary
and the administration says it's a
crisis
but now it's a catastrophe i saw a dead
body floating in the rio grande river
other people have died we heard the
report of the nine-year-old that doesn't
even count
the number of people who die along the
way it also doesn't count the three or
four hundred people are called the
godaways
not the thousands who are coming in and
going to the border agents
but the hundreds every night who are
crossing
they have their their bad actors their
drug
many of them are gang members or they're
smuggling drugs human traffickers that
are evading arrest
it's creating a dangerous situation it's
a catastrophe
the president hasn't spoken on it to my
knowledge the vice president's never
gone down there to actually get a
bird's-eye view
the president's embraced the green new
deal policies like canceling the
keystone pipeline
that one stroke of a pen ended
thousands of labor union jobs good
paying jobs but even
more heartbreaking is that the
communities that would have benefited
from all of that commerce occurring
in some of the most rural areas and most
economically challenged areas in our
country
they ran through an entirely partisan
two trillion dollar spending package
they called it coveted relief but only
about nine percent of it
actually had anything to do with
continuing to recover from the damage
that covet has caused this country
and now i'm sure the president will talk
about it tonight
a 2.3 trillion dollar air quotes
infrastructure bill that is actually an
infrastructure bill
in fact they've been a little bit more
intellectually honest now they're
calling it human infrastructure
well i think most americans when you
think about infrastructure you think
about roads you think about bridges you
think about broadband
you don't think about human
infrastructure but that's what's being
pitched today and it's being pitched on
a partisan basis
without even attempting to get a single
republican vote
americans did not elect president biden
to enact any of these partisan policies
they trusted him to come in and make
deals
to settle for something less than 100
percent but something that was going to
be embraced
by more of the american people versus
half
which is about where the president is
today
and he's pursued this for the first
hundred days i hope he changes minds
changes his mind but here's one reason
why i'm not optimistic
his most audacious action in my opinion
is placating the far left and
entertaining
the idea of nuking
the senate legislative filibuster
in this very chamber 21 years ago
then senator biden declared that
defending the filibuster was about
defending compromise
in moderation the promises he made on
the campaign trail
the promise he made on the day of his
inauguration
he noted that that his speech was one of
the most important he would ever give as
senator
defending the filibuster it's a shame
that president biden
isn't demonstrating the same political
courage
that senator biden did two decades
earlier
the kind of courage that we're seeing
today demonstrated by senators mansion
and senator simon
cinema instead
the president has entertained the far
left's push to eliminate the filibuster
and destroy this institution
to end bipartisanship and compromise is
really no longer a necessity
so that any piece of let fringe
legislation can pass with a simple
majority
the president a 30-plus year defender of
the filibuster
should know better than anyone he knows
that the left is demanding
a bastion bargain trading two years for
the far left to have free reign in
exchange for permanent destabilization
destabilization of our republic
embolding future demagogues on both ends
of the spectrum
our country doesn't need more partisan
pain ring
or political brinksmanship from this
administration
or from either party that's why i stood
against nuke in the filibuster
about three years ago and i will as long
as i'm a u.s senator
there are plenty of republicans like me
who are willing to work with president
biden
and even put some of our supporters out
of their car out of their comfort zone
for the good of this nation
in fact when i was sworn in i said i'd
work to find common ground in areas
where we may agree and i'd vigorously
oppose policies
where we do not unfortunately to this
point i've only had the opportunity
to do the latter
the willingness to negotiate has only
been a one-way street on the part of
republicans
i went to the white house to try and
find common ground on another
bipartisan covet package but it's
ultimately up to the president whether
he leads on bipartisanship instincts
or follows his advisers who are pushing
him to keep governing from the left
quite frankly it doesn't matter what the
president says about bipartisanship
and uniting the country it's what he
does
and tonight i hope we'll see it for the
good of our great nation
thank you madam president
madam president the senator from kansas
thank you madam president on january the
20th
president joe biden gave his inaugural
address to the american people
saying that in order to overcome the
challenges we face
as a nation and to i quote to restore
the soul
and to secure the future of america
requires more than words
it requires that most elusive of things
in a democracy
unity unity i in the quotes and he says
for a second time
unity in fact he mentioned the word
unity nine separate times throughout his
inaugural remarks
unfortunately that unity president biden
preached about is nowhere to be found
100 days in office and there's been zero
bipartisanship
from the white house on any major issue
we've seen zero effort by the white
house to take any republican idea or
concept seriously
in fact they've done very little to
reach across the aisle engage
republicans
or have a serious conversation with us
they've shown that they are
interested in are not interested in
bipartisanship
as they continue to jam through their
radical agenda
and seek power grab after power grab
we've seen
a record number of executive orders the
first partisan coveted relief bill
steps to grant d.c statehood to tip the
powers of scale
a directing that threatens private
property rights the cornerstone of our
democracy
an attempt to federalize elections and
destroy election integrity with hr1
threats to eliminate the filibuster
increase gas prices for americans at the
pump
efforts to pack the supreme court
disguided measures to pass the green new
deal
calls to defund the police mandates to
allow biological boys
to compete in girls sports and tax
increases on all americans
and much much more madam president
things are changing in d.c
history will record president biden as
having spent more money
than any other president in u.s history
in his first 100 days
i'm warning everyone grab your wallets
history will record president biden's
misguided policies
as making our nation less safe having
created a health crisis
a national security crisis and a
humanitarian crisis
at the southern border what i hope
and fear from president biden this
evening is not likely to be covered in a
speech
he's going to try to explain to us even
though our economy is recovering and we
just borrowed and spent two trillion
dollars
from our grandchildren why we now need
to spend another two trillion dollars
and why he needs to raise your taxes to
do it
he's going to try to describe the
legislation he wants passed
as a so-called infrastructure bill when
less than five percent of it is going
towards roads and bridges
he's trying to try to convince americans
of something that is a misnomer
and not a truth what he won't tell you
is that this is a recipe to kill kansas
jobs
and an economic catastrophe for this
nation
last week president biden signed into
law a bipartisan bill
i introduced alongside senators bill
cassidy and tina smith
to lower prescription drug prices for
the american people
additionally we unanimously passed a
bill out of the ad committee regarding
carbon markets
these are both great examples of the
unity the president spoke of in his
inaugural address
democrats and republicans coming
together to deliver solutions for the
american people
these are good first steps and in case
there is more opportunity for
bipartisanship
let me tell you where we can and should
start we can start with an
infrastructure practically
package that actually rebuilds our aging
roads bridges
and waterways invest in future
generations
ensures high-speed internet for all
americans and incentivizes innovation
we can start with staying the course
laid out by operation warp speed
and getting more shots in people's arms
so we can reach herd immunity sooner
rather than later we can start with
people getting back to work and finally
unleash our economy
to pre-pandemic levels angle we can
start with getting all our kids
back in school as president biden said
in his inaugural
address and i quote again this is our
historic moment of crisis and challenge
and unity is the path forward in quotes
if he truly puts unity above all else we
can accomplish great things for the
american people
for it is unity that will see this
country come roaring back
not president biden's radical partisan
ways that have further divided this
nation
thank you madam speaker and i yield the
floor
adam president senator from arkansas
sadly the united states is in the midst
of the deadliest
drug epidemic in our nation's history
caused by some of the deadliest drugs
ever created it appears
that more than 80 000 americans died
from a drug overdose last year
by far by far the biggest killers
were lab made opioids such as fentanyl
which are cheap to produce
and easy to mix with other street drugs
such as heroin
these lethal cocktails have devastated
countless communities and families
across our nation too many parents have
come home to a dead child
who mistakenly took a prescription pill
or a so-called party drug
laced with this deadly fentanyl
illicit fentanyl the kind created an
underground chinese drug labs
or smuggled across our poorest southern
border by mexican cartels
is made only only
to addict and kill for these dark
terrible purposes
fentanyl is unsurpassed in the tragic
history of addiction
it is 50 to 100
times stronger than morphine
it's two two milligram
fennel the amount equivalent
few grains of salt
enough kill grown man
just last december police arrested a man
in arkansas
carrying seven pounds of fentanyl
depending on the purity of that fentanyl
that would have been enough to deliver a
fatal dose
to up to 1.5 million
americans and that's far
from the biggest fentanyl bust that
police have ever met
that means that every time our border
patrol stops drug mule
coming across our southern border
every time the coast guard intercepts a
drug runner's vessel
in our waters and every time a swat team
raids
bonds as schedule 1 prohibited
substances this decision closed a deadly
loophole that drug dealers were using to
escape punishment for poisoning our
citizens
while still allowing legitimate
researchers to apply for and obtain
approval to research these analogs for
potential
medical or scientific breakthroughs
the evidence suggests that this law
enforcement action has been getting
results
since the class-wide scheduling went
into effect in early 2018
law enforcement encounters with
uncontrolled fentanyl analogs
plummeted by almost 90 percent
of course our work to solve the opioid
epidemic is far from finished
we still have much to do to dismantle
the cartels and the drug
trafficking networks that spread
fentanyl and its analogs
and mix it with other drugs but
the dea's efforts to control fentanyl
analogs were a step
in the right direction last year the
senate voted unanimously
unanimously to extend the dea's
emergency scheduling of fentanyl
but that extension is now set to expire
so we have the opportunity in fact i
would say we have the responsibility
to permanently control these deadly
fentanyl analogs
so law enforcement has the legal backup
it needs to take these dangerous
drugs off the streets if congress
doesn't act
this emergency scheduling order is set
to expire
next week the authority of our border
patrol to seize these drugs as they
cross the border
will be dramatically reduced cartels
will once again be able to exploit
loopholes to evade prosecution and
chinese super labs will get
right back to work inventing new and
creative ways to repackage
fentanyl and to kill even more americans
we cannot let that happen
i've introduced a bill to solve this
problem once and for
all by merely eliminating the expiration
date
on the law that protects us against
these fentanyl analogs
i'm asking my colleagues to approve it
just like we did last year
unanimously
i'd also like to urge my democratic
colleagues to disregard
the liberal activist groups that are
lobbying against controlling these
deadly fentanyl analogs
because they help to use it as a
bargaining ship a bargaining chip
to reduce criminal penalties for the
most serious drug
traffickers think about that more
americans died of a drug overdose last
year than in any other year in our
history
yet these liberal activists are trying
to help the drug traffickers who spread
these very poisons
if they succeed drug dealers will have
an easier time killing americans for
profit
and prosecutors will have to waste
valuable resources
proving that each new form of fentanyl
they encounter is in fact a deadly drug
we cannot play politics with this bill
trading the lives of innocent americans
for more lenient treatment
for cartels and super labs protecting
americans from deadly fentanyl should
not
be treated as a bargaining piece or
poker chip
i asked my colleagues to think of the
victims and to think of the urgency of
this measure
i'm offering this bill on behalf of tens
of thousands of americans
who are with us just last year but are
not
today because of these deadly synthetic
drugs i'm offering on behalf of the
countless americans who can still be
saved
if we act so i urge my colleagues to
support this measure
and therefore madam president as if in
legislative session
i ask unanimous consent that the senate
proceed
to immediate consideration of s-1410
introduced earlier today further i asked
unanimous consent the bill be considered
read a third time in the past
and the motion to reconsider be
considered made and laid upon the table
is there objection reserving the right
to object
the senator from new jersey i'm deeply
grateful for my colleague and my friend
uh from arkansas to bring this to the to
the floor of the united states senate
there is an
urgency that he described that i agree
with 100 senators here not one state has
not been touched
devastatingly by the fentanyl epidemic
and these analogs
present a crisis to our country lives
are at stake and so i share his sense of
urgency i am hoping that we can work
together to find a way
to stop as he put it these cartels and
these drug labs from wreaking such havoc
on our country i believe
that together we can find a solution in
fact there has been constructive talk
across the capital bipartisan talk about
finding a way
to come to some kind of accord in
addition to that
i'm hopeful that there are other bills
out there that are have the same
ambition
the same goal the same sense of urgency
that i believe should be part of the
discussion
for example policies uh like the ones in
the stop
fentanyl act which i understand senator
markey will be introducing in the senate
very soon
i believe that we should have time in
the judiciary committee to work
on a longer longer-term solution that
could not just deal
with the international cartels not just
deal with these horrific drug labs
but also empower people who are addicted
uh to begin
not to be punished simply with the
criminal justice system
but to find ways to provide treatment
and support
to people who are struggling with
addictions to this horrific
drug so with that i would like to object
objection is heard and present
the junior senator from arkansas i thank
my colleague from new jersey for those
remarks i do hope that we can find a
solution but time is not on our side
this emergency scheduling order expires
next week senate's not in session
next week i know that we want to
empower addicts as the senator from new
jersey said
that we want to help get them treatment
that they need to get back on their feet
that's a goal i share
we are talking though about drug dealers
drug traffickers cartels
chinese super labs and if we do not pass
an extension in my bill
a permanent extension of this emergency
scheduling order
it is the addicts who will be hurt
because
their drug dealers and these cartels and
the super labs
will simply begin to flood our streets
once again
with the synthetic fentanyl analogues
which i remind you
again can be 150 times
more potent than fentanyl itself which
is 50 to 100 times more potent than
morphine
so i hope my democratic friends will
reconsider in the short time we have
this week
and we'll be able to pass a permanent
extension
of this scheduling order madam president
madam president the junior senator from
new jersey
i just want to say in conclusion before
i switch to another topic
i appreciate the center from arkansas's
willingness to look not just at his bill
but also the power of a potential
uh bipartisan extension or what however
we can deal with this
because the urgency does exist we are in
a crisis
but i rise today to speak uh in support
of ambassador powers nomination to serve
as administrator for the united states
agency
for international development or usaid
now the mission of usaid is to advance
the values
of democracy throughout the world on
behalf
of the american people this mission has
never been more critical than today and
if confirmed
ambassador power will lead an agency
tasked
with responding not only to the global
crisis of covet 19 and its devastating
impact on vulnerable people
across the world but some of the most
pressing challenges facing
the united states and the international
community
global democratic backsliding
human suffering caused by sexual and
gender-based
violence climate change and violent
conflict around the world
now ambassador power is an extraordinary
public servant
she has distinguished herself in her
career and she is
more than capable of leading usaid's
efforts
to address these global urgencies and
she is
clear-eyed and sober about the
international challenges
she will face usa aid will face as well
over the past four years experts and
career professionals within the usaid
were
unfortunately silenced decisions were
politicized and recruitment and
retention were
inadequate ambassador power will be the
kind of leader this agency now needs
to restore integrity transparency
rebuild morale
among the dedicated professionals who
drive usaid's critical
mission ambassador power also
understands that the u.s
will remain a global leader really must
remain a global leader
able to counter the influence
of china's aggressive diplomatic and
development agenda
if usaid is seen once and again by our
international partners this mission of
countering china will be
stronger if usaid is seen as a competent
and trustworthy partner
we will build along our coalitions to
counter
china's aggressive actions president
biden could not
have nominated someone more ready
more capable than ambassador power she
has had
an impressive career has and and she has
from her work as a pulitzer prize
writing journalist
to spending eight years in the obama
administration and national security
council
and then as ambassador to the united
nations where she championed the rights
of women
atrocity prevention lgbtq rights
receiving consensus with other countries
on vital u.s interests
while going toe-to-toe with our
adversaries this is one of our
more experienced international
diplomats from america that we have
today
and by elevating ambassador powell to
the national security council
president biden has made it clear that
development
and humanitarian assistance will be in
an integral component
to our meeting our foreign policy
objectives that is
important that we understand that
development and humanitarian assistance
are a critical part of our foreign
policy and so finally i just want to end
with something that ambassador power
shared in her most recent book it's
something that i think speaks so well
to her humility to her willingness to
learn
and to why she will be the leader of the
usaid and i say
our entire nation and the world needs
right now ambassador power wrote about
meeting
a meeting she had with the ambassador
from central
from the excuse me from the central
african republic
charles dubin who described to her the
horrific violence taking place
in his country she wrote about during
that meeting
that she told him she didn't have an
agenda she just wanted to learn
from him about what was happening in her
country
she then writes that she that he started
speaking and then stops and
gets very emotional
she assumes he is getting emotional
about the horrific violence
in his country but he says to her and i
quote no it's not that ambassador
what is happening in my country is
terrible more terrible than anything
that has ever happened to us before but
i am emotional
because you are here
the united states of america is the
greatest country in the world
and you america
are here that is the vision
of america that has defined ambassador
powell
powell powers career that has guided her
the awesome responsibility of
representing this nation and her values
her rootedness and the ideals of our
nation
humility grace compassion
thoughtful leadership i've known
ambassador powell since she and i were
very young
it's been decades now a friendship and
connection
say many things about her but at her
core is decency
and honor she will represent the best of
us
she is exactly the leader we need right
now
as we navigate increasing
and pressing challenges facing the world
and our country i am
thankful it'd be enough for ambassador
powell to retire it'd be enough
for her to say i have served my country
and like cincinnatus returned to her
plow but clearly
her calling is not yet
fully been answered she will continue
should this body believe it and endorse
it
to serve this country she will continue
to honor the united states of america
she will continue
to be a credit to our nation and the
world
and that is why i urge my colleagues to
support her nomination
i yield the floor
the senior senator from iowa i'm five
minutes late coming to the senate floor
i was supposed to be here on the
fentanyl
issue to support senator cotton
and i know that the objections been
raised
but i want to people to know how
important i think this issue is
so today we were considering hopefully
unanimous consent to pass
a scheduled fentanyl substance bill
proactively scheduling fentanyl
related substances ought to be a big
priority
because too many americans lives have
been lost
to reject this critical measure
some wrongly assert that controlling
fentanyl
analogs is partisan and unnecessary
that's simply untrue legislation to
schedule
fentanyl analogs is a bipartisan issue
just last year this body passed a
bipartisan
15-month extension of the bill
unanimously
also such authority is necessary
the cedc estimates
that fentanyl analogs killed 50 000
americans in the last 12 months
we must prevent overdose deaths
prevention is possible when we use our
laws
to force china to stop the flow
of fentanyl analogs opponents of
permanent scheduling assert
that the authority is broad and could
result in too many
arrests but since the drug enforcement
administration
placed fentanyl analogues in schedule
one
the justice department has convicted
only
80 people under that authority
so too many people being arrested as an
argument against
permanent extension is hogwash
this authority hasn't resulted in vast
and
wide prosecutions rather
this authority is targeted and
deliberate
and of course that's the way it should
be so if controlling fentanyl analogs
is in fact bipartisan and this necessary
why isn't supporting legislation then a
no-brainer perhaps because of heightened
partisanship
democrats can't vote for legislation it
helps law enforcement
or maybe they can't be seen as
supporting any drug control law even if
it's law enforcement
or maybe they can't be seen as
supporting any drug control law even if
it
could save thousands of lives this
position
goes against the unfortunate truth
that 50 000 americans have died from
these deadly fentanyl
analogs politics has no place
above human life as frustrated as i am
by this
it's not my nature to throw in the towel
i'll always work hard to find
middle ground that's why i'm asking
every senator to support
senator cotton's permanent extension or
at
a minimum my bill the temporary
extension of fentanyl scheduling act
this bipartisan measure extends the
authority
to schedule fentanyl analogs for 14
months
it keeps fentanyl analogs in schedule
one
until july 2022 with
which is long enough for the
administration
to come to a permanent scheduling
solution and allow for a deliberate
and transparent dialogue with congress
so simply put we need to give ourselves
enough time
to find a solution to this major problem
causing 50 000 lives to be lost every
year
as history shows us lengthy fentanyl
scheduling legislation is not
controversial
i'm simply asking for a similar
bipartisan approach
now my bill is the only bipartisan
temporary extension bill
on the table i'm grateful for senator
hassan and shaheen for teaming up
with me and senator cornyn we can't
limit ourselves
in the fight against fentanyl it's with
this in mind
that i urge all my colleagues to support
either a permanent extension
or my bipartisan bill and to extend the
authority
to schedule fentanyl analogs for 14
months
i yield the flaw
the junior senator from florida madam
president
americans are worried about inflation
new polling shows that 87
of americans are concerned about the
rising cost of household items like
diapers
and gas and groceries that's up from 77
just last month and they have good
reason to feel that way right now
reports show that a third of american
households making less than fifty
thousand dollars
in annual income are buying less because
of increasing prices
and more than one quarter of all
households report
the rising prices on goods are causing
them to purchase less
just last month or this month the bureau
of labor statistics reported that over
the last 12 months
food prices are up and gas prices have
risen 23 percent
that means since biden was elected gas
prices have increased about 70 cents per
gallon
across the nation year over year
consumer prices increased 2.6
in march that's up from an annual 1.7
percent increase in february
this is all in addition to statements
from some of america's largest
corporations
like procter gamble and kimberly clark
which recently announced that they are
increasing prices
on a number of their products that
includes essential household goods like
toilet paper and diapers
the evidence of inflation is right in
front of us
just look at these numbers which show
the percentage change in
average unit prices versus last year
grocery is up 2.6 percent
household goods of 5.2 percent baby care
of seven percent
general merchandise of 7.1 percent
wages never go up as this fast so who's
it hurt
the poorest and those on fixed income
businesses are expecting prices
increases to continue
according to data from fact set 47
s p companies have mentioned inflation
on their earnings calls for
q1 2021 that is more than during
any quarter in the last 10 years
on their most recent earnings call
procter gamble chief financial officer
andre
scholten said the commodity cost
challenge we face this year
will obviously be larger next fiscal
year
and who gets hurt the most when their
inflation rises not the rich
it's working families especially those
on low
and fixed incomes i grew up poor and
watched my parents struggle to put
food on the table i know just how much a
slight rise in prices can hurt a family
because i saw it growing up and that is
what is happening right now across our
nation
we know that the buy demonstration is
worried about this they know that rising
costs caused by their massive spending
are bad for americans but they won't say
it
while they are reportedly worrying and
private about the effects of their
spending plans
they've had a different message in
public on april 13
new york times reported that officials
and aides at the white house
and the department of treasury have been
holding private meetings for months
discussion inflation and conducted
in-depth internal analysis
for senior officials and president biden
the article goes on to say
quote mr biden's aides are sufficiently
worried about the risk of
spending fueling inflation that they
shaped his infrastructure proposal
which is yet to be taken up by congress
to fund a 2.3 trillion dollars
over eight years which is slower than
traditional stimulus
madam president i ask unanimous consent
that this article be placed in the
record
without objection madam president the
content
and conclusions of these meetings and
working groups have not been disclosed
or made available to the public while
privately worrying about the same issue
i've been sounding the alarm on for
months
the buying administration continues to
mislead the american public
and ignore the threat of inflation over
the last two months i've asked the
national economic council about their
plans to fight inflation
and protect american families i've
written federal reserve members asking
what can be done to help families
who are seeing skyrocketing gas prices
and increasing mortgage rates
i've called him president biden and
federal reserve chair powell to allow
their clear
plan to address inflation and rising
prices that threaten american families
i've yet to get a straightforward or
acceptable response
i've yet to hear them acknowledge this
very real threat
or propose a solution to protect
families
so today senator braun and i are making
a simple request
that the byte administration share with
the senate all of its notes
memos and reports regarding their
discussions and plans to mitigate and
prevent growing
inflation inflation is a very real
threat to the well-being of already
struggling families
and the last thing american families
need is to be misled by this
administration
right now democrats in washington are
living in a fantasy land where debt
doesn't matter
spending has no consequences inflation
is impossible
but the reality is is that inflation
does have consequences
it is the duty of everyone here
especially the president of the united
states to be open
and transparent with the american people
that's what about what's happening with
inflation
madam president there is no reason the
biden biden administration should be
hiding this information
americans deserve to know the
consequences of massive government
spending
and they deserve leadership that will
show some fiscal responsibility when it
comes to their taxpayer dollars
i look forward to all my colleagues
supporting this effort to increase
transparency
madam president as of an aft if as if in
the legislative session
i ask unanimous consent the senate
proceed to the consideration of center
resolution 185
submitted earlier today i ask unanimous
consent that resolution be agreed to the
preamble be agreed to
the motions to reconsider be considered
made and laid upon the table
with no intervening action or debate
is there objection madam president
the senior senator from ohio and
president reserving the right to object
madam president no no serious economist
across the ideological spectrum are
concerned about inflation right now
no one is hiding information at the
white house
i'm in meetings all the time with white
house officials talking about this
package
no one believed first of all no one's
hiding information
no one believes what the senator of the
the junior senator from florida
is saying about this uh perhaps some
millionaire senators
want to make this into an issue and i
hear that over and over
and over but i talked to people like jay
powell nominees chair of the federal
reserve
nominated by president trump for that
position
um he he of course keeps his eye on
these kinds of things
but he has expressed no strong concern
about inflation
and we even know that when some experts
have been concerned they've been wrong
we saw what happened in
2008 after too many elites worried about
inflation
what we really needed was to increase
wages and get people back to work the
result
from 2008 was a recovery that was too
slow for most people
while so many of these big costs
continue to rise our economy looks a
whole lot better today
than it did last year but we can't
compare where we are today with where we
were last year
we were in the brink of a once in a
generation health and economic crisis
this time last year millions of people
mostly
low-wage workers lost their job our
economy ground to a halt as we tried
to stop the spread of the virus this
year we've made good progress with the
american
rescue plan as the presiding officer
from wisconsin knows getting shots and
arms and
money and pockets and kids back in
school and people back to work
but our recovery is far from over just a
few just moments ago fed chair powell
said they were seeing some temporary
upticks because things were so dire
last year we still have a low but we
still have a long way to go
the bigger risk adam president to the
economy is not doing enough
to raise workers wages and to invest in
the infrastructure that allows our
economy to grow
we know corporate leaders we know
millionaire senators we know
people at the top have done very in many
cases
done very very well for this but we know
millions of workers many of them hourly
workers
have lost jobs we know millions of
workers so-called essential workers one
essential
worker said to me works at a grocery
store i don't feel essential
frankly i i feel expendable because they
don't pay me much
they don't protect me work those are the
people we should be we should be
looking after i want to raise wages i
want to bring down costs
that's exactly what the jobs plan in the
family plan will do
bring down health care costs make child
care more affordable create more housing
people can afford bring down energy
bills make
work getting to work cheaper and easier
with better transit these are the costs
that have been rising
and eating away at family budgets for
decades
if my colleague from florida is so
concerned about the cost of living and
raising a family
i hope you'll join me to allow medicare
to negotiate directly with drug
drug companies to bring down prices for
seniors i hope you'll join us in
investing in child care
to bring down the cost of child care i
hope will join us
as we work to create more housing
bringing down housing costs i hope
you'll join us
to raise the minimum wage my first
speech on this floor
14 years ago 14 years ago my first
speech on this floor was to raise the
minimum wage
and we did and it hasn't been raised
since that's what the senator from
florida
and the senator from indiana can help us
with but we know madam president most of
the conservative elites in this country
most won't say out loud what this
inflation alarmism was really about
they don't want to invest in the
american people they don't want to do
anything to make americans
hard work pay off they'd rather try to
scare people
can't spend this money because there
might be inflation they don't want us to
do what too many
have failed to do to put money in
people's pockets and raise wages
and rebuild infrastructure i'd ask my
colleagues
to listen to the words of a worker from
west virginia pamela garrison who
testified at our
first ever work listening session our
dignity of work
session in the banking housing committee
yesterday she said we're seeing
corporations make billions every quarter
in profit
but then when we ask for a minimum wage
we're told increase we're told that
no one will raise the cost of stuff oh
that'll cost jobs
funny corporate executives never seem to
say they'll have to raise prices when
they give themselves bonuses
it's just we'll have to raise prices if
we incur the minimum wage and
this um same miss garrison also said you
know they call me part of the working
poor
the words working and poor shouldn't be
in the same sentence
and she's right about that real expenses
for most families have gone up for
decades
along with corporate profits in the
stock market executive compensation has
exploded upward
and workers wages haven't kept up
executive compensation
productivity is up executive
compensation's up profits are up workers
wages are flat
that's the problem that's what we should
be working on
madam president i object
objection is heard madam president the
junior senator from florida
and president the decision by my
colleague to block this resolution is
clearly disappointing
let's remember what this was about this
was about transparency
they just blocked the senate from
requesting basic information that's
going to help all
all americans and let's look at these
numbers again
just in the last 12 months grocery
prices are up 2.6 percent
household care is up two percent baby
cares up seven percent
general merchandise have seven point one
percent we're clearly seeing inflation
senate democrats are just objected to
transparency that means they're against
getting the facts
against insuring accountability and
against getting the american people the
information they need
to make smart decisions as prices keep
rising
87 of americans are worried about the
rising cost of goods
apparently so is the white house so
don't the american people deserve
the same information about what is
happening with the economy
floridians deserve to know the truth
about inflation and so the people
so do the people of ohio why does my
colleague want to keep them in the dark
this administration is telling the
american people one thing
but saying something else behind closed
doors that's
wrong the american people deserve the
truth inflation is real
it's happening it's hurting american
families it's
time prison biden does something about
it and i'm extremely disappointed my
colleague who's actually today is
helping the president mislead
the american people i yield the floor
you
the senior senator from ohio consent to
address the house for 10 minutes
the house sent it for 10 minutes i
looked i'm sorry sent it for 10 minutes
good point well the presiding officer
and i were in the house together so
but that was like a long time ago
without objection thank you
today madam president we mark workers
memorial day when we honor and remember
workers
who've laid down their lives on the job
i've worn on my lapel
since i was in the house madam president
a pen
depicting a canary in a bird cage given
to me at a workers memorial day rally
in lorraine ohio in the late 1990s this
pen
depicts a canary going down in the mind
of the it suggests the
mine worker taking a canary down in the
mines if the canary died
from lack of oxygen or or from toxic gas
the mineworker got out of the mines he
had
no union strong enough to protect him
and no government that cared enough to
protect him in those days to me this pin
represents the role of government to
support the middle class and those who
aspire to the middle class
it represents the progress we've made in
the society we continue to fight for
every
year we every day here we know the story
coal miners took the canary down in the
mines
throughout the 20th century we've worked
to change that
we passed worker safety laws and
overtime decay we
ban child labor we pass clean air safe
drinking water laws we enact social
security
in medicare in workers rights and
women's rights and civil rights
but despite that progress over the last
year too many workers have felt a whole
lot
like those minors they felt like they're
on their own a moment ago i mentioned
the grocery store worker
in cincinnati who said they tell me i'm
ex
essential but i feel expendable that
grocery store worker and thousands of
others
have been on the front lines of this
pandemic risking their lives so
americans could keep food on their table
and get their packages delivered they're
changing linens in hospitals and
driving buses and stocking shelves and
supermarkets then
workers go home at night and and are
anxious that they might spread the virus
and affect their family we know that
hundreds of thousands of workers have
been exposed to the virus on the job
thousands have died it's hard to get an
exact count of how many
because the previous administration
didn't bother to keep track
we know the food and commercial workers
reported last summer that more than
16 000 grocery store workers have been
exposed
more than 100 had died we know those
numbers keep going up
the national nurses united has recorded
at least 3 200
health care workers have died in meat
packing plants the toll has been
been horrific last summer 16 000 workers
had been affected
the vast majority of them black and
brown workers more than 230 died
and yet all of last year the trump
administration and too many large
corporations failed to protect their
workers
the corporate lawyers that ran the labor
department
from the top down refused to issue
workplace
safety requirements corporations ran a
lot of feel-good tv ads saying thank you
to essential workers claiming these
workers the heart of their companies but
workers didn't ask for a pr campaign
they needed protections on the job
this workers memorial day today we
celebrate it every year
remember the american workers who've
lost their job their lives on the job
from this virus sometimes from gun
violence sometimes from workplace
accidents
we honor them best by fighting to
protect these workers and their fellow
workers
to make their hard work pay off
yesterday in the banking and housing
committee
we held the committee's first ever
listening session it was purely a
listening session no
senators got to ask questions we just
came to listen
with workers from ohio and around the
country hear how the financial system
affects their jobs and their lives they
shared powerful stories about their work
about how companies and economic
policies prevent their hard work from
paying off we heard
from a distribution worker in ash kabula
ohio
he told us we rarely go a few weeks
without an injury largely because of the
insane pace we work at
we have suggested that slowing the pace
even just a little would improve
safety and could save money we were told
injuries don't cost this company much
money
we heard from a wells fargo call center
worker who talked about how the bank
misclassified her to avoid paying
overtime they put her on salary
they said she was management they worked
her more than 40 hours they never paid
her an overtime dollar
we heard from a full-time gig worker who
works for multiple corporations like
uber and
instacart he works full time he has zero
benefits
because these companies claim he's an
independent contractor
we heard from a michigan worker who lost
her job when a private equity firm
brought out bought out her company they
laid off 3 100 workers in the detroit
area
and they pocketed the money we heard
from a worker in west virginia who
talked about working your whole life
and never seeing that hard work pay off
she said
working poor the term working poor
should not be
two words that go together if you work
hard
you should be able to get ahead in this
country if you you
if you love this country you fight for
the people that make it work if even
a global pandemic where america's
workers have been on the front lines if
even that will
get corporations to rethink their
business model
that treats workers as expendable it's
time to stop
letting them run the company that's what
the new banking housing
and urban affairs committee is all about
wall street had its chance
they failed if corporate america won't
deliver for its workers
then we have to create a better system
centered on the dignity of work that
means
safe workplaces the big administration
is taking us
steps toward finally and
issuing an osha emergency temporary
standard we went a whole year in the
pandemic
where the president united states simply
refused and the corporate lawyer that
ran the department of labor simply
refused to issue
any standards on workplace safety think
about that
now it means laws and policies reward
work like the earned income tax credit
in the child tax credit which the center
for new hampshire is
in this the junior center for new
hampshire's here and has been supportive
of that a strong overtime rule
ending misclassification that robs
workers of their wages and their rights
it means a
strong labor movement unions give people
power in the job people ought to have
the option
if they choose of joining a union
allowing them to join together
to make their workplace safer it's
workers who make our economy successful
it's workers that allow corporations and
wall street investors to rake in record
profits
it's time for that hard work to pay off
for all workers
no matter if you punch a clock or swipe
a badge or work for salary
or work for tips or take care of your
parents or take care of your children
that work should be rewarded in this
country when you love for
when you love this country you fight for
the people awake at work
on workers memorial day and the other
364 days of the year
and president i yield the floor
under the previous order all
post-cloture time has expired
the question is on the nomination
is there a sufficient second
there appears to be the clerk will call
the role ms baldwin
mr barrasso mr bennett
mrs blackburn mr blumenthal
mr blunt mr booker
mr bozeman
mr braun
mr brown
mr burr miss cantwell
mrs capito mr cardin
mr carper mr casey
mr cassidy miss collins
mr coons mr cornyn
miss cortez masto
mr cotton
mr kramer mr crapo
mr cruz
mr danes
ms duckworth
mr durbin
ms ernst mrs feinstein
mrs fisher
mrs gillibrand mr graham
mr grassley
mr hagerty
miss hassan
mr hawley mr heinrich
mr hickenlooper
miss hirono
mr hoeven
mrs hyde smith
mr inhofe
mr johnson
mr kane mr kelly
mr kennedy
mr king
miss klobuchar
mr lankford
mr leahy
mr lee
mr lujan
miss lummus
mr mansion
mr markey mr marshall
mr mcconnell
mr menendez
mr merkley mr moran
ms murkowski
mr murphy mrs murray
mr ossoff
mr padilla
mr paul
mr peters mr portman
mr reed
mr rish mr romney
ms rosen
mr rounds
mr rubio
mr sanders
mr stass
mr schatz
mr schumer
mr scott of florida mr scott of south
carolina
mrs shaheen
mr shelby
miss cinema miss smith
miss davenau mr sullivan
tester mr soon
mr tillis
mr toomey
mr tuberville
mr van hollen
mr warner
mr warnock
ms warren mr whitehouse
mr wicker
mr wyden
mr young
foreign
senators voting in the affirmative
baldwin brown casey
hassan king leahy
moran murray rosen
and sass senators voting in the negative
ernst grassley and lummus
this stop now miss dabnow aye
mr rubio mr rubio no mr lee mr lee
[Music]
no
mr burr mr burr i
mr brasso mr brasso no
miss collins miss collins
miss smith miss smith aye
mr marshall mr marshall no
mrs feinstein mrs feinstein aye
mr romney mr romney
mr schumer mr schumer i
mrs shaheen mr shaheen aye
mr scott mr scott of south carolina no
mr reed mr reed i
mr cornyn mr cornyn aye
mr cardin mr cardin aye
mrs blackburn mrs blackburn no
mr wyden mr wyden aye
mr peters mr peters i
mr cotton mr cotton no
mrs fisher mrs fisher aye
mr bennetts mr bennett i
mr graham mr graham aye
ms warren miss warren ah
mr inhofe mr inhofe aye
mr coons mr coons aye
this is hyde smith mrs hyde smith no
mr danes mr danes no
[Music]
mr warner mr warner aye mr heinrich mr
heinrich
aye mr bozeman
mr bozeman no
mr murphy mr murphy i
mr kane mr kane aye
mr scott mr scott of florida no
mr blunt mr blunt aye mr mansion mr
mansion
mr booker mr booker i
mr tester mr tester i
mr mcconnell mr mcconnell i
mr haggerty mr hagerty no mr merkley mr
merkley
i
mr cassidy mr cassidy no
mr tubberville mr tuberville no
miss cortez masto miss cortez masto
ah
mr wicker mr wicker aye
mr kennedy mr kennedy no mr crapo
mr crapo aye
mrs capito mrs capito i
mr sanders mr sanders
mrs gillibrand mrs gillibrand
now
mr tillis mr tillis no mr portman mr
portman
aye mr markey mr markey i
mr kelly mr kelly aye
mr lujan mr lujan aye
mr carper mr carper
mr warnock mr warnock aye
mr rono mr rono aye
mr johnson mr johnson aye
mr brawn mr brawn no
mr van hollen mr van hollen
ms duckworth ms duckworth ah
mr hickenlooper mr hickenlooper
mr hoeven mr hoeven no
mr menendez mr menendez
mr schatz mr schatz i
miss murkowski ms murkowski
you
mr hawley mr holly
now
mr lankford mr lankford no
mr padilla mr padilla ah
miss klobuchar miss klobuchar i
miss cinema miss cinema
mr durbin mr durbin ah
mr blumenthal mr blumenthal
mr sullivan mr sullivan no
mr young mr young
mr cruz mr cruz no
you
mr white house mr white house
you
you
you
mr ossoff mr ossoff
are there any senators in the chamber
wishing to vote or change his or her
vote
if not the yeas are 68 the nays are 26th
the nomination is confirmed
under the previous order the motion to
reconsider
is considered made and laid upon the
table
and the president will be immediately
notified of the senate's action
under the previous order the senate will
resume legislative session
the clerk will read the title of the
joint resolution
resolution for the third time counter
number 48 sj res 14
providing for congressional disapproval
under chapter 8 of title 5 united states
code
and so forth okay
mr president the majority leader
mr president could we have ordered
now as we approach the 100-day mark of
this new congress the senate's about to
take its first major step
in fighting climate change in a moment
the senate will vote on reinstating
common sense rules to reduce methane
emissions
it'll be the first time the senate
democratic majority
has used the congressional review act
and it's no mistake
that we have chosen to use the law first
and foremost
on the subject of climate change under
this democratic majority the senate will
be a place
where we take decisive ambitious and
effective action
against climate change could we have
order mr president order please
of course reducing methane emissions is
not the only thing we need to do to
fight climate change but it's a very
significant and large first step
methane accounts for roughly a quarter
of all the human-caused global warming
that has
transpired since the industrial
revolution
reducing these methane
rather restoring these methane-reducing
rules
will be one of the most significant
climate actions that the senate has
taken
in more than a decade i urge my
colleagues
to vote yes and commend senators
heinrich king and marky for their great
work on this
issue as for the a's and nays
do i have to do that is there a
sufficient second
there is there appears to be
the question is on passage of the joint
resolution
the clerk will call the this baldwin
esparasso
young no
yep kids
hi thank you
mr bennett this is blackburn
mr blumenthal mr blunt
mr booker mr boseman mr braun
mr brown
mr burr
ms cantwell this is capitao
mr cardin mr carper
mr casey
mr cassidy
thanks
yes
miss collins
i guess so i don't see her thank you
mr coons mr cornyn miss cortez masto
mr cotton mr kramer mr crapo mr cruz
mr danes ms duckworth
mr durbin
ms ernst
mrs feinstein mrs fisher mrs gillibrand
mr graham
mr grassley
mr hagerty
miss hassan
mr hawley mr heinrich mr hickenlooper
miss hirono
mr hoeven
mrs hyde smith mr inhofe mr johnson
mr kane mr kelly mr kennedy mr king
miss klobuchar mr lankford mr leahy mr
lee
mr luhan ms lomas
mr mansion mr markey
thank you
mr mcconnell
he's gonna be back
mr menendez mr merkley
mr moran ms murkowski
mr asa mr padilla
mr paul mr peters
mr portman mr reed mr risch
mr romney ms rosen
mr rounds mr rubio
mr sanders mr sass
mr schatz mr schumer mr scott of florida
mr scott of south carolina
mrs shaheen mr shelby miss cinema miss
smith
ms stabenow mr sullivan mr tester mr
thune mr tillis
mr toomey mr tuberville yep
thank you mr van hollen
mr warner mr warnock mr
ms warren mr whitehouse mr wicker
mr wyden mr young
senators voting in the affirmative
baldwin blumenthal
booker brown cardin carper
casey collins coons cortez masto
durbin gillibrand graham
hassan heinrich hickenlooper kane
kelly king klobuchar leahy
mansion menendez murphy murray
ossoff padilla portman reed
sanders shots schumer shaheen
cinema tester warner warnock
white house and widen
miss warren i
mrs feinstein i
senators voting in the negative
blackburn blunt
bozeman burr hornen cotton
crapo cruz danes
fisher hawley hoeven hyde smith
inhofe johnson lankford lummus
marshall rubio scott of florida scott of
south carolina
sullivan foon tillis tuberville and
young
mr marky i mr mr rish no
mr cassidy no
mr kennedy now
mr grassley no
miss rose and i
i do thanks
miss murkowski
mr wicker no mr mcconnell
mr mcconnell no
mr merkley i
ms murkowski no
mr peter's eye
mr brawn
mr braun no mrs capito
okay this is capitao no
sorry sorry
no
mr hagerty no
mr lee no
mr moran no
you
mr sass no
mr romney no
miss smith
i know
mr bennett eye
to one third
you
mr lujan i
mr barrasso no
okay i'll be ready i'll be
on point
are there any letters in the chamber
wishing to vote or to change
his or her vote if not the yeas are 52
and the nays are 42
and the joint resolution has passed
under the previous order the motion to
reconsider is considered made and laid
upon the table
the senator from delaware my president i
ask unanimous consent that the senate
be in a period of mourning business with
senators predators speak
therein for up to ten minutes each
without objection
on president i ask unanimous consent
that when the senate resumes
consideration
of s 9 14 on thursday april 29th
the following amendments be reported by
number and that they be the only
amendments in order
to s 9 14. rubio scott
number seven one as modified
shaheen number one four six one
kennedy number one four six nine and lee
number one four seven two
further that at 11 30 a.m on thursday
april 29th
the senate vote in relation to the
amendments and the order listed
with 60 affirmative votes required for
adoption of the league amendment
and passage of the bill further that the
that upon disposition of the amendments
amendment number
1460 as amendment if amended be agreed
to
the bill be considered red a third time
and at 1 45
pm the senate vote on the passage of the
bill as
amended with two minutes for debate
equally divided
prior to each vote and finally
the motions to reconsider be considered
made and laid upon the table
all with no intervening action or debate
can you modify it and clarify that it's
1 30.
145. a correction here we go uh the bill
will be considered
read a third time not at 1 45 but at 1
30 the senate vote on passage of the
bill is amended
is there objection without objection
my president i ask unanimous consent
that the appointment
at the chair uh appear separately in the
record as if made
by the chair without objection
one moment please
let's go back to 145. forget what i said
about 1 30.
uh we'll uh may ask unanimous gonna lock
it in at 1 45 this week said the first
time
without objection
uh madam president i asked unanimous
consent that the appointment at the desk
appears separately in the record as if
made by
the chair without objection
that the senate proceed to the
consideration of sres 186
submitted earlier today the clerk will
report
esros 186 honoring the humanitarian work
of baristas de souza mendes
and so forth
without objection the senate will
proceed to the measure
uh when president i uh ask unanimous
consent
uh that the resolution be agreed to the
preamble
be agreed to and that the motions to
reconsider be considered
made and laid upon the table with no
intervening action
or debate without objection
mad president i ask unanimous consent
that the senate precede
the consideration of s res 187 submitted
earlier today
the clerk will report srs187
congratulating the university of
wisconsin badgers on winning the 2021
national collegiate athletic association
women's
ice hockey championship
without objection the senate will
proceed to the measure
my president i ask unanimous consent
resolution to be agreed to
the preamble be agreed to and that the
motions to reconsider be considered made
and laid upon the table with no
intervening action
or debate without objection
madam president i ask unanimous consent
that the senate recess until 8 25 pm
today
upon reconvening proceed as a body to
the hall of the house of representatives
for the joint session of congress
provided
under the provisions of h conres 30
and that upon the dissolution of the
joint session the senate adjourned until
10 a.m on thursday april 29th
2021 that following the prayer and the
pledge the morning hour be deemed
expired
the journal of proceedings be approved
today and
the time for the two leaders be reserved
for their use later
in the day in morning business be closed
and upon the conclusion of morning
business the senate resumed
consideration of challenge number
34 s 914
drinking water and wastewater
infrastructure act
of 2021 as provided under the previous
order
without objection we will gather in the
senate chamber at 8 15
p.m this evening to proceed as a body to
the house
of representatives for president joe
biden's
address joe biden first delaware and
never elected president
of the united states madam president
there's no previous further business to
come before the senate
madam president i ask that at recess
under the previous
order
the senate stays in recess until 8 25 pm
you